let's jump to this other very
contentious social issue ooh i saw this
on rodeo joe rogan references his 14
year old daughter
and uh
you know pro-choice in a heated debate
about abortion he said you know you're
not going to force a 14-year-old who's
been raped to carry the rapists baby i
thought it was interesting because he
had on seth dillon and they both made
their points
they it was well well stated on both
sides i think seth dillon made some
interesting points let's read this so
we'll talk about it joe rogan clashed
with the conservative commentator during
a heated debate about abortion
is is seth dylan as a commentator why
what are you just kidding me i thought
he was actually
he's the ceo of the babylon but i think
i mean
even bringing up his uh but he but he
like does political commentary on
twitter the polarizing podcaster he's
polarizing he's the most popular
previously stated he's 100 for a woman's
right to choose full stop no joking uh
joking no joe rogan no joking joking
that's it he's joking from now on
wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong i i
will i will bet 100
okay no a gentleman's bet i never liked
putting money a gentleman's vet good sir
joe rogan that if i sat down with him
and we had a conversation he would
recant that statement oh for sure
outright
so we'll talk about it so uh he says
there are women who have been raped who
should not have to effing carry some
rapists baby rogan exclaimed there's
women who have been assaulted before the
age of 14.
dylan the founder of uh he's not the
founder of babylon he's the ceo adam
adam ford's the foundation right
wrong new york post fact check
he said there are people who have been
born of rape and are alive right now and
are pro-life they go around speaking and
say i had a right to live they will go
around making a case and they were born
of rape
so uh i actually i i totally understand
what seth seth dylan is is saying i do
agree with joe in this capacity about
for one a 14 year old i i think that's
not a viable pregnancy like way too
young to be able to to uh carry a baby i
mean it's
that's the age where the doctor's gonna
make a decision but i i fall on the the
more libertarian side of the government
can't force someone who was already
forced to carry a baby in their body
that's a difference though the reason i
say joe rogan would recant that
statement if i talk to him i guarantee
you joe rogan is not in favor of uh
abortion at nine months for elective
reasons i i hate this debate so much and
the reason i hate it is because
it's like not it's not due to the fact
that i don't want to talk about it it's
the fact that abortions because of a
rape are exceedingly rare in comparison
to what most abortions are right it's a
way for the left to kind of get away
from talking about what abortion
actually is where they just say oh
there's a if a 14 year old was raped you
wouldn't you would support her carrying
a rapist baby and it's like that is not
even that is a significant
it's really really simple it's really
simple when the left says that your the
response to joe rogan is you know what
joe i'm going to give you that one uh so
then do you think that all other
instances where it's not would that be
okay to ban well so if you want to talk
about banning the 93 of elective
abortions with no reason given or
whatever then i agree with you okay rape
excluded women can get abortion can get
abortions if they've been raped and now
you agree to ban 93 of abortions well so
seth did i watched i watched this
episode yesterday in full and seth did
that because they started talking about
the case in nebraska there was this big
case in nebraska recently that the media
lied through their teeth about there was
there was this mother and she had a 17
year old daughter who was 23 weeks
pregnant so six months the facebook yes
so so this this is a fully formed baby
this and it's 23 weeks nebraska had a 20
week abortion man this woman gave her
daughter abortion pills and they
stillborned the baby at their house they
then took it and they burned and buried
the body and the police got hold of this
because of a tip from somebody and so
they subpoenaed their facebook dm or not
subpoenaed they uh
they got a search warrant for their
facebook dms because they talked they
talked about us like the daughter was
like i can't wait to get this effing
thing out of me and they're under
they're now being charged with multiple
felonies for this but the media lied
about it because they said facebook
turned over dms to the police like the
headlines from so many media outlets
were literally facebook turns over dms
to the police to prosecute teenager for
having an abortion without mentioning
the fact that they did this at home for
the fully formed baby that they burned
and buried in their in somewhere so uh
absolutely psychotic and not surprised
the media lied seth brought that up to
joe yeah so they started talking about
and joe was obviously against that like
he said like that's ridiculous and and
everything and that's the thing like if
when joe says you know he previously was
100 for a woman's right to choose he's
not 100 from women's right now i think
that's out of context that statement
because it's that i don't think that's
not something he would say with no
pretext he was probably saying that in
reference to something maybe maybe i
didn't see the show do you remember greg
when he said that did he come off as
saying no he didn't say he said well no
he said he's like in favor fair point he
said quote it gets weird when the baby
gets like six months old i know that
some states have late term abortions and
sometimes you need one for medical
reasons right the woman could die if she
gives birth like it's a decision that
people have to make i am 100 for a
woman's right to choose but as a human
being just a person observing things
there's a big difference between a
little clump of cells and a fetus with
the eyeball and the beating heart funny
for anybody to pretend there's not okay
so actually there's there's a beating
joke
part of it nice job newsweek you screwed
that one up he says where do you draw uh
his guess is where you draw the line is
right where do you draw the line that's
the question it's what i call a human
issue it's a very complicated issue it's
so fraught with emotion it's so
political but that question is something
the left cannot answer they cannot
answer where they draw the line and
that's why
yeah so that's why they constantly bring
up things like
would you would you let that 10 year old
carry her rapist like the story we saw
in ohio of the 10 year old who
apparently who got raped by i called
that i called that by her mother's
boyfriend yeah so it didn't so it ended
up not being a little immigrant it ended
up not being it ended up not being a
hoax that a ten-year-old child was
impregnated by rape but it ended up
being the fact that it was her mother's
boyfriend who was a leader no no it was
a hoax so uh the reason i say that is
because obviously it did happen
obviously there was a pregnancy
obviously there was a crime committed
but
when you look at the statements from the
local government and it was in ohio
right yeah and they said she could have
she could have gotten the treatment
but they did not do it they went
somewhere else instead so what i'm
saying is it is a hoax in the sense that
they drummed up a big political story
for political play without the full
context exactly what about the 16 year
old girl florida what about the 16 year
old girl in florida who's an orphan she
has no parents she's pregnant she's 10
weeks pregnant
um oh yeah we have that story actually
the judge ruled she's not mature enough
to have an abortion the judge ruled that
she's not mature enough to have an
abortion that she's not allowed to make
the decision for herself she is within
the uh timeline where an abortion would
be permissible under florida law really
they're not allowing it and they're not
allowing it because um a parent or
guardian would have to make that
decision she doesn't have any of that
well then she's the she's the guy she's
the guardian but she's not the legal
guardian the state is the legal guardian
of this girl right that's annoying i
think this is crazy i think this is
crazy yeah i mean she's within the the
legal limits of the of the law
right
well and they're not allowed to die
human life should not be should not be
taken
yeah i do think that there should be
exceptions for rape and incest for sure
and i do think that there should be
limits
this isn't rapist this whole like no
this this case is not rape but i i do
think that there should be you know i
don't think nine months obviously and i
do think that it should be very tight to
near conception
um well so this is this 16 year old and
i don't think anyone should do it but
like i also think there should be is
this 16 was a 16 year old uh it wasn't
statutory rape or anything like that it
was like no she's she was with a fella
and she said he's not capable of helping
out he's not going to be a dad he's like
not around and what's the justification
for why she should be able to get an
abortion is 16. it's within the it's
within the laws of the state of florida
florida florida has a 15 week that's
right so she's under the time limit
wow that's crazy
yeah i don't like it man the way i see
it is like if a woman feels the need to
terminate a pregnancy like she's been
let down by society let down by her
family not entirely well that's that's
what i like that's what i see like i
said i see i see it as a problem when
women feel like when a woman feels like
there is no way out there's besides
nobody talks about right there's
something that nobody talks about that i
have experienced among my friend group
over the past you know however old i am
um and that joe biden has certainly
picked up on they have a new plan to
promote their abortion message by
targeting men and telling men like hey
be pro-abortion right
i have known so many women
married unmarried with a guy who have
been coerced into getting an abortion
you know i knew one woman who her
husband just didn't want to have kids
and was like if you don't abort these
babies this baby i'm gonna leave you
that happened over and over in that
marriage i have another friend it was
before she got married
all she has to do is say
no if i have it you can't
sure
sure there's always the thing you can
say right well i mean the issue is
there's always the other thing that you
can come up with when a woman gets
however she has legal control in court
finances she felt very coerced and
forced into getting this abortion that's
that's what ended up happening whether
you think she should have felt that way
or not that's how she felt and i've
known that to happen to many other women
where the reason they get the abortion
is either
to keep the man or you know to do what
they're told or to not get beat or
whatever it is
men do coerce women to getting abortions
that happens and we have to deal with
that as well it's not just the woman
being like well you know i think i want
to do this today men are culpable in
this as well and nobody talks about like
the depression and other like you know
things like that that can happen to
women after they have an abortion
and like it's disgusting and that's
disgusting that it happens but this is
something that the biden administration
has said out loud like kamala harris in
did like a round table with a bunch of
abort like abortion activists and she
was talking about like what are you
going to tell you are you going to tell
your son that when if they get a girl
pregnant that like she was saying this
could affect you because your son is now
having a baby and it's like okay so
we're gonna teach men that they're not
responsible for their actions i had the
same exact thought with that and i've
actually had the conversation with my
son who's 12 i've been like listen
if something happens and
you know god forbid this happens and
someone gets pregnant mommy is here
i have a stable home mommy is here i'll
be happy to be the grandma
like it you know that's right i know
that sounds ridiculous
like i just want to put that out there
like we're just a culture that doesn't
value life or personal responsibility
that comes with it and i think that
needs to change that's i don't look i i
our culture is decaying and collapsing i
think cultural enforcement is everything
the laws are meaningless when your
culture won't uphold the law so
everything we're talking about is really
just rooted in
like american values and and culture has
just eroded the point where you have
one faction which is most of the
democrat voters the anti-trump people
with no moral framework whatsoever and
then you have the traditional american
moral framework the democrats have
become so insane when it comes to
abortion like they they're literally
nuts like they they tried to pass a bill
well they did pass a bill in the in the
in the house
that would have nullified every state
pro-life law across america and it would
have allowed for abortion at any time
for any reason at all and i think the
median american voter does not support
that by by polling data like the median
ameri the median voter in america
supports abortion within like you know
a few certain weeks but democrats have
become so nuts on this issue that
they've made it like they think the
overturning of roe v wade was going to
be their saving grace in this midterm
and i don't think that because i don't
because the american people are not as
insane on abortion as that as the
institution and like abortion for no
limits for no reason at all repealing
the high demand amendment taxpayer
funding
that is in the democrat party i mean the
thing is the democrats want us to kill
our babies and they want to they want us
to sterilize our children well they're
they're sterilizing their children and
they're getting abortions so the future
will be christian conservative
okay
so it's always worked out well in the
past i'm not saying it's i'm not saying
it's good or bad i'm saying that's the
reality of
one political group removing their
children's ability to reproduce and then
literally removing their children and
they're trying to remove our children
arizona just past school choice right
that was a big thing court deangelis was
tweeting about so yeah this if
conservatives went on this front it's
it's the end of the leftist ideology
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there